what's up my fellow geeks zaki here with
geek culture and today's video we're
going to show you how to change
your playstation 5 covers
in midnight black and cosmic red
and moving over here we have the new
colorways for the dual sense controllers
starting with darth vader over here we
have the starlight blue
the nova pink and my personal favorite
the galactic purple kind of reminds you
of thanos doesn't it and all of these
so you can play your games with style
and comfort and speaking of comfort
let's talk about today's sponsor
secretly
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
circulators especially the all new 2022
titan evo with its revamped 4-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support if pu
leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colours including
this lovely frost blue the tyson evo is
even magnetized along the hit pillar to
stick on the headrest of course there
are even more new features so do check
them out at secretlab.co
alright so with that let's show you how
to change out the console covers boy am
i excited to change out these covers
because honestly speaking the white just
doesn't fit
our studio aesthetic
out of the box we have the console
covers
check that out oh
wow i really love the sheen on this it's
like a semi-gloss it's not a fingerprint
magnet that is
wonderful so good all right and what we
have here is the
the playstation
side of the console cover
you can see that it's completely
hollowed out the playstation logo over
here
can you see that
all right
so all we need to do now is to install
it and it's very very very simple
now the first step is to layer on the
side
then
find the playstation logo
what i like to do is to get more grip i
like to use my body so i'll orient the
base
towards me
okay
where the playstation logo is
pull up and push towards you
boom so actually slides out so pull up
slide back so with this side done we're
gonna flip it
now what you want to look for is the
port side all right
this top corner right here again
pull up and push towards you done
very easy huh so i'm going to show you
how to install it
but the disk drive side
we've got the disk drive slit here on
this cover
now what you want to do
is
kind of set it in place
and you want to push it in you hear that
again on the other side
flip it
kind of sets right
again down and
push
and ladies and gentlemen geeks and all
your playstation 5
it's already
[Music]
we've seen how the midnight black looks
like
let's
try out the cosmic red
are you guys ready let's check out the
cosmic red check that out
similar fashion little bit of sheen here
bit of texture as well but this is
semi-gloss
also not a fingerprint magnet
very nice very very very fast
so let's do a quick one again cool
done put this in
and there you have it
playstation 5 now
and cosmic red
abby how do you find it midnight black
or cosmic red red red
i like red too
[Music]
and there you have it folks quick and
simple to install just look how well all
the colors complement each other it's
beautiful and i mean sony has really
given it some thought and i'm so happy
that they launched the new playstation 5
console covers and you can expect more
different designs in the near future
well thanks for checking out this video
we hope you enjoyed it if you have any
questions do let us know down in the
comments below and while you're down
there don't forget to like and subscribe
until then this is zeki signing off
[Music]
you